Ce genre de choses.
Notre président en particulier, il se bat contre les pirates.
(Rires)
Je suis très sérieuse.
Il a acheté un bateau à 13 millions de dollars
pour combattre les pirates
et 60% de la population meurt de faim.
Ils nous protègent toujours de forces étrangères.
Cela mène au troisième point : la militarisation.
Les dictateurs survivent en suscitant la peur
et ils utilisent l'armée pour éliminer les voix dissidentes,
même s'ils essayent de donner l'impression
que l'armée est là pour protéger la nation.
Ils éliminent et détruisent les institutions
afin de ne pas être tenus responsables.
Avez-vous un pays fortement militarisé ?
Cela mène au quatrième point, ce que j'appelle la cruauté humaine.
Quand nous parlons des animaux,
nous parlons de cruauté animale quand ils sont maltraités
car il n'y a pas de charte reconnue par l'ONU,
pas de charte des droits des animaux.
Premier point : tous les animaux naissent égaux.
Nous n'avons pas cela.
Quand les animaux sont maltraités, nous parlons de cruauté animale.
Quand il s'agit d'humains,
ce sont des violations des droits de l'Homme
car nous supposons qu'ils ont tous des droits.
Certains d'entre nous se battent encore pour notre droit à des droits.
Dans ce cas, je ne parle pas de violation des droits de l'Homme.
Quand, si dans un pays, vous avez un problème avec le président
et que la pire chose pouvant arriver est qu'il vous interdise la présidence,
vous êtes chanceux.
Dans mon pays, quand vous avez un problème avec le président,
vous fuyez, vous disparaissez, vous vous volatilisez
car ils peuvent encore vous trouver en Turquie.
Les gens comme moi ne peuvent plus vivre au Togo.
Les gens comme moi
ne peuvent pas vivre plus d'un mois au même endroit
car nous ne voulons pas être retrouvés.
La maltraitance des gens,
le genre de cruauté se produisant en toute impunité sous les dictatures
va au-delà de l'imagination humaine.
Les histoires de certains activistes qui ont été tués,
leur corps jeté à la mer,
qui ont été torturés
jusqu'à perdre l'ouïe ou la vue --
ces histoires me hantent encore.
Parfois, en tant qu'activiste,
mourir m'inquiète moins que la façon dont cela arrivera.
Parfois, j'imagine tous les scénarios.
Que feront-ils ? Me couperont-ils d'abord les oreilles ?
Ou me couperont-ils la langue car je les insulte constamment ?
Cela semble cruel, mais c'est la réalité.
Nous vivons dans un monde cruel.
Les dictateurs sont des monstres cruels
et je ne le dis pas pour être sympa.
C'était la dernière caractéristique.
La liste n'est pas finie,
mais c'est la dernière chose que je veux partager sur les autocraties
pour que vous considériez les risques dans votre pays.
Il est important de reconnaître les libertés que vous avez aujourd'hui
car certains ont dû donner leur vie pour que vous les ayez.
Ne les prenez pas pour acquises.
J'aimerais aussi que vous sachiez
qu'aucun pays n'est condamné à être opprimé,
et en même temps,
aucun pays ou aucun peuple n'est immunisé contre l'oppression et la dictature.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)